[Musik]
leute wir machen heute das grundrezept
für pfannkuchen ich weiß ja als
pfannkuchen immer gehen bei uns war das
bremer so jeden sonntag gab es von
kuchen und wenn man besonders darauf
hatte dann gab's abgefangen kuchen die
kann ich euch gerne auch mal zeigen
heute geht es um das grundrezept wie
gesagt es geht auch super easy ich habe
hier schon die zutaten bereit die lege
ich jetzt hier allem eine große schüssel
und zwar fangen wir an mit mehl und dazu
gebe ich eine prise salz auch wenn wir
jetzt höchste pfannkuchen machen das
salz hebt jetzt einfach noch mal den
süßen geschmack ihr könnt übrigens auch
herzhafte pfannkuchen machen dann erhöht
ihr die salzmenge auf einen halben
teelöffel und las dem zucker weg und
hier
apropos zucker gebe ich den auch schon
mit dazu führe dass ganz kurz um und
dann kommt schon die trockenen zutaten
dazu und da gibt es einen geheim trägt
er hat mir meine mama damals erzählt
einfach mineralwasser mit kohlensäure
reingeben das macht noch mal so einen
richtig schönen tag und eine andere
konsistenz und dazu geben wir milch und
es ist ratsam wenn die zutaten also
einem die flüssigen jetzt nicht ganz
gerade aus dem kühlschrank kommen die
mir ich habe hier zum beispiel kurs in
die mikrowelle gegebene mit lauwarmen
ist dann verrührt sich das besser
miteinander und die letzte zutat die
nicht fehlen darf das in eier und jetzt
hören wir alles zu einem glatten teig
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt schon fertig wir
müssen allerdings noch eine sache
beachten will das mit zugedeckt eine
halbe stunde lang auf zimmertemperatur
ohne da passiert folgendes das habe ich
euch mal vorbereitet detail verändert
sich ganz leicht selber maßgebend für
die konsistenz später beim auspacken der
wird ein bisschen dk ich kann euch das
hier mal zeigen und im vergleich jetzt
der dennoch nicht gut ist
na also jesus ein bisschen flüssig genau
deswegen haltet die halbe stunde zeit
auf jeden fall ein also nicht im
kühlschrank geben sondern auf
zimmertemperatur hätten klein cut und
ich gehe rüber zum herd jetzt habe ich
in einer beschichteten pfanne butter
erhitzt nimmt auf jeden fall mutter ist
ein toller geschmacksträger
und genau da gebe ich jetzt eine kelle
von meinem pfannkuchenteig rein bin
gespannt ob der erste was wird ihr kennt
das phänomen der erste wird immer
hässlich ist so überall bei krebs ich
weiß nicht warum es so ist dass der
erste nie was wird wir schauen mal
[Musik]
das gericht gut aus ja ein wunder
ob man erster franken ist fertig und er
ist toll geworden also ich würde sie
sonst werden die ersten nie was wir sie
nicht raus und jetzt nehme ich dann
einfach raus aber die anderen ja dieses
erwirkt hat echt von der schönen die
gibt es auch im shop ich verlinke euch
sowieso immer alles was ich benutze
unten in den druck genauso wie die
mengenangaben und denkt daran was sie
immer wieder ein bisschen butter
nachgibt in die pfanne
denn der teig sorgt auch ein bisschen
butter auf
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon lieben so
schnell sind die pfannkuchen
hergezaubert was mit ihren allerliebsten
auf anfang kuchen schreibt nochmal in
die kommentare mein favorit ist in echt
seien immer erdbeermarmelade ich liebe
das auch pfannkuchen was sagst du in der
nächsten runde auch gut auch gut
schreibt ja genau schreibt uns gerne mal
rein was ihr am liebsten mit vechta ist
muss auch mal inspirieren oder aber wir
sagen ja ich mag
das ist aber nicht okay ich schreibe
euch wie gesagt alles genau eine infobox
schaut da rein hinterlassen wieder in
münchen nach oben mit euch gefallen hat
und dann kostenloses abo natürlich und
dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem
nächsten rezept taxis
[Musik]